le président mesdames et messieurs comme
le disait sénateurs imminent qui a siégé
près de 18 ans dans cette assemblée
la révolution est un bloc l'histoire de
france est un bloc la révolution pour
aller dans le sens du président
retailleau est un bloc et dans la
révolution nous prenons condorcet et
saint-just danton et robespierre valmy
et la vendée le général dumas el général
bonaparte
nous prenons tout parce que parce que
parce qu'en fait en vérité monsieur le
sénateur nous n'avons pas le choix c'est
notre histoire avec des choses glorieuse
avec des choses plus compliquées et même
avec des choses qui ne sont en rien
glorieuse mais qui sont franchement
sombre peut-on me désigner une période
de l'histoire un homme ou une femme qui
ayant fait quelque chose
serais tu de toute évidence et dans tous
les aspects lumineux mais n'aurait pas
sa part d'ombré
sérieusement
je sens qu'au sénat on me dit il y à
gérard larcher
je
je crains monsieur le président que même
vous plus sérieusement avant moi il ya
eu l'abbé grégoire ici monsieur le
président monsieur le président même lui
même lui dans notre histoire et et
glorieuse et est compliquée et vouloir
procéder à une forme d'épuration
mémorielle me paraît aussi dangereux
d'une certaine façon que vouloir
procéder à d'autres types d'épuration
nous devons garder notre histoire en
face évidemment et au fond c'est ce que
nous faisons c'est pas toujours facile
d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le seul
point sur lequel je me distingue un tout
petit peu de votre question monsieur le
sénateur fou dit est ce que est ce que
vous allez empêcher qu'on réécrivent
l'histoire mais la vérité dans le
processus scientifique qu'est l'histoire
c'est que l'histoire se récrie en
permanence la vision que l'on a
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
grands hommes ou de grande époque où de
grands événements et peut-être un peu
différente c'est vrai de celle qui
prévalait il ya trente ans où il ya 200
ans bien sûr bien sûr on ne lit plus
aujourd'hui le règne de françois 1er
comme on le lisait à l'époque où
quelques années après mais justement
nous sommes au sénat le haut lieu de la
république et nous travaillons sous les
auspices de saint louis
bah oui parce que c'est l'histoire de la
france je voudrais dire monsieur le
sénateur pour aller dans votre sens que
comme vous sans doute j'ai été
profondément choqué parce que je pense
que ça traduit une profonde
je ne trouve pas le mot mais en tout cas
quelque chose qui ne va pas j'ai été
prof au quai profondément choqué qu à
fort de france
on déboulonne les statuts le victor
schoelcher à fort de france qui étaient
de même et peut-être pourrions nous
engager un combat comme à celle du
sénateur profondément déçu non pas
choqué parce que on a essayé de
rattraper le coup mais profondément déçu
que la république
la quatrième d'abord la cinquième
ensuite ne reconstruisent pas la statue
au général dumas qui a été fondue par
les nazis en 1940 1941 le général dumas
qui dit beaucoup plus de choses sur ce
qu'est l'idéal républicain
le père d'alexandre celui dont
anatole-france disais et je vais dire le
mot parce qu'il montre combien notre
histoire est difficile anatole france
prix nobel de littérature disait le plus
grand des dumas c'est le fils de la
négresse intel france aujourd'hui
le mans est impossible à juste titre
mais dans la bouche d'anatole-france
c'est le plus bel hommage républicain
qu'on puisse faire alors peut-être
monsieur le sénateur si vous le voulez
nous pourrions vous et moi
militer pour la reconstruction de la
statue du général dumas fébrile champ
[Applaudissements]